jeff i have a quote here that i hope is
correct it says there's no way this
would have had the same appeal if it
were made today
is that something you said okay why
um well i mean i think the appeal might
be there
but the
shelf life would be over with in a week
you know the the viral video world we
live in now things are just constantly
you're being bombarded constantly every
day
every hour it seems like with new
content a new new
you know short video or a video of any
length really just it's this constant
flood
and because of that
you're
you know there's not enough time for
something to really i think um develo
you know create a shelf life and
so we have that's what's what we're
you know fortunate to have with this
video
is shelf life
um i mean there's still loads of people
who've never heard of it you know i mean
lots of peop it's not that
you know much of a
um
you know a publicly recognized uh uh
title
but we have some
cult
notoriety and certainly in the music
world but everything's changing
constantly and i i don't kid myself you
know that it's just
there'll come a time you know it gets
less relevant you have to keep working
harder at keeping it out there keep
keeping that
your your name or your
your uh your work
in some fashion out there it's hard
but but i'm very fortunate to have
something to work with
even if it's cult
you